you roasted Donald Trump yeah who at the
time was you know Donald Trump and now
he is the leader of the free world whoo
now I'm curious how did he because you
had to work up close with him and you're
roasting him he doesn't seem like a guy
who would handle a roast well tell us
what happened it is odd he loves being
roasted i roasted him twice actually but
he doesn't laugh so you have to just
keep going til you get him to break yeah
is it because it's almost like he loves
being the center of it he loves being
the attention the attention of being
roasted but he doesn't want to laugh at
himself and Al Frank and senator Al
Franken made this point recently he said
the guy he's been what he's been
watching him like a hawk for like the
entire campaign he said he doesn't laugh
he'll smile or he might you know sort of
laugh at a situation but he's not
someone who would ever laugh at himself
he finds that I think the challenge of
letting everyone know that he doesn't
think it's funny even though he wants to
be roasted yeah I had a couple good ones
I said Donald um you know about his
bankruptcies which he doesn't think is
very funny I said you're mad I read your
book the art of the deal it had four
chapter Elevens pretty good but you know
they didn't like that I'm roastmaster
general so now that he's president I'm
hoping to get a call to be a secretary
of offense Jeff I need four insults
about North Korea by free ah yes mr.
president I'll meet you over there
oh you're gesturing I'm actually
ghostwriting Trump's new book with them
oh yeah yeah it's called mine Kampf is
bigger than your calm
[Applause]
you